one thing that you wanted to do tonight
which I thought was kind of exciting
which is you are reinvigorating the
Clippers and they've been through a lot
a lot of people are very very happy that
you took after it took over the team
Donald sterling obviously that was a
fiasco and he is gone now his wife his
ex-wife still comes to games is that
correct he is his wife still does come
to game she's a you know she did a good
service to really help free the team up
for me to buy it and I appreciate that
the players appreciate that she gave us
the chance to move on because he was not
really that he was not going to sell and
she did a lot towards making this happen
and I think everybody obviously feels a
lot better right that you've been
brought in so it's it's what much face
bags you look back at the history of the
Clippers it's not a happy history mm-hmm
and so I bought the team about a year
ago in the kind of unusual circumstance
at the time and we said hey something's
happen here number one this may have
been a nutty thing but the people know
the Clippers are but people want a new
Clippers they want a happy ending this
story this is kind of downtrodden thing
with this kind of funny ruler boom let's
switch it around right and I bought the
team so late we couldn't do much but now
we're we're introducing you know the new
Clippers the new Clipper logo for
example oh wow right there
[Applause]
that's it this is the new logo it is the
new one I saw that we'll watch it
tomorrow actually I'm so relieved
because I'm I was told you almost went
with this one which would have upset me
it was clever but it doesn't look good
on a t-shirt and I'm glad that you
didn't do that well that's exciting you
haven't seen our mascot yet no you have
a new mascot looks just like the thing
on the left